you can't worry about the people that  don't like you you need to focus on the  people that do like you and I I feel  like this might help a lot of people  who've been debating on putting  themselves out there I want you to turn  your fear into empathy and compassion  think about this you guys make a video  somebody comes on to that video and  leaves a comment that you suck that you  don't know what the [ __ ] you're talking  about that you're ugly how would you get  hurt like whatever the nastiest things  they can say think about how [ __ ] up  that person's life is another human  being took time out of their day because  they're hurting so much to try to hurt  someone else you shouldn't be mad at  them you should definitely not feel sad  for yourself you should have compassion  for the person that trolled your page  because that is not a good life